[Musique]
ce dimanche 16 octobre s'est tenu la
journée départementale des personnes
âgées un rendez-vous incontournable pour
nos gramouns qui après deux ans
d'absence n'est pas passé inaperçue plus
de 10000 visiteurs ont répondu à
l'invitation du département et de ses
partenaires au jardin de l'État qui
accueillait pour l'occasion la deuxième
date du Salon des Seniors organisé par
la guerre
vous voyez il y a du bonheur ici au
Jordan l'État les gens sont heureux nos
seniors partagent discutent s'amuse
aussi et c'est ça que nous voulons nous
voulons d'une solidarité
intergénérationnelle et dire à tous les
élèves de la Réunion mais à 6 points
fait pour la Réunion et notre devoir
aujourd'hui c'est de les accompagner
c'est le rôle du département bien
évidemment mais je salue aussi le
travail de tous les partenaires des
communes mais aussi surtout des
associations qui sont sur toute la
réunion au service de nos seniors je
rends hommage au travail des agents du
Département et puis j'étais avec le
gouvernement la semaine dernière au
Congrès des départements de France j'ai
dit à madame la Première ministre que
nous voulons aller plus loin dans
l'amélioration de l'habitat et il faut
que sur la ligne budgétaire unique que
nous obtiendrez des financements de
l'État pour plus d'amélioration de
l'habitat le problème des retraites
aussi de nos personnes âgées la Réunion
il faut qu'on en discute et qu'on trouve
des solutions j'ai vu avec le directeur
et le président de la Caisse générale
des secrétaires sociales pour qu'on
aille plus loin parce que nos seniors
nous aînés ont des droits parfois
attirer pas ses droits là et donc c'est
pour ça qu'il faut faire un gros travail
d'information pour l'accès aux droits
au programme de cette journée des stands
d'information et des ateliers animés par
les professionnels du Bien Vieillir un
marché forain et des activités en tout
genre
[Musique]
par le débattement donc nous est bien
une journée en l'honneur de la troisième
jeunesse qui s'est terminée sur une
bonne note de musique
[Applaudissements]
je comprends qu'on vient je t'aime
retrouvez le salon des seniors à
Saint-André au colosse le 19 novembre et
au grand kiosque du tampon le 4 décembre
prochain
[Musique]